could we potentially see you in season
two either as olivia or a new
cast member
are you are you open to that
i'm of course open to it
the white lotus finale was literally
everything and more the series was
everything more truly how did you feel
about olivia's ending you know i think
that
olivia had a little bit coming to her
but then at the same time i feel for her
there's some things that i think that
olivia needs to work out with herself
though
yeah just a few things so hopefully
hopefully she grows a little what did
you think about the ending
overall
armand is the one who died and it was
jane
who did it but it was an accident i mean
i when i was reading it i did not see it
coming at all because the entire time
because we had we got episode by episode
so the entire time i was trying to
figure it out at the same time so
i kind of had the same process as you
guys did just a little sooner it was
definitely by seeing it though our mom
like going to the bathroom in the
suitcase everything was just
it was amazing
when you read that in the script like
was there a group text or what were you
guys all thinking like is is this
actually happening right now well my
first question was
is he actually going to be doing it how
are they going to make this look real
real
no
i was like
could you imagine if i said yes it's
real and then murray for the rest of his
life
it
this interview would have blown up and
gone everywhere
oh no this just makes me want to gouge
my eyes out so they only gave you guys
the scripts week by week was that to
sort of protect the secrecy of the
project we get it we get it whenever
mike is done and then hbo approves the
scripts and then they get sent to us so
it's just not all at the same like clump
of time i feel like olivia truly she was
really iconic to me on every level but
also of course a little bit sociopathic
in a way very much so there's there's
definitely a few little mean bones in
her
why do you think though she ultimately
did not rat paula out for her
involvement in the robbery i think that
she was just really heartbroken because
yes olivia's a really good friend but
that is what friendship is to her so
paula not being her number one per se
and breaking that like girl code that
olivia had in some weird
form
broke her and
she was really sad and heartbroken and
disappointed in the friendship so i
think that she was still trying to
process it herself and then there's also
the underlying olivia streak in her of
she's gonna save this for one day oh
nice nice right on what did end up
happening to kai like we know but we
don't know we didn't actually see it i
think he got fired sadly fired and fired
maybe
i don't know if my parents pressed
charges
i'm curious probably they would probably
press charges it would definitely press
charges i feel they're the kind of
people i think that would press charges
and then sue yeah i know this show so at
first it was announced as a mini series
and then i feel like they saw the
popularity of it and so now it is
getting a season two with a whole new
cast a whole new white lotus location
what are your thoughts
on that i'm just so excited for mike and
dave and everyone a part of the show
because i think they deserve this mike's
writing is just so much fun and so
incredible and whatever he brings to
season two we'll just elevate it even
more and be a blast to watch could we
potentially see you in season two either
as olivia or a new
cast member
are you open to that i'm of course open
to it okay so you wouldn't say no are
there conversations happening on that
front yeah
okay if it were up to you would you
reprise the role of olivia or would you
like it oh yeah she's a blast she's so
far from myself so it's so fun to just
like
dive into this and i'm so terrified of
olivia so it's really fun
playing a character that you're scared
of
yeah how was the reception i feel like
everyone was equally as terrified of
olivia they were like literally there's
i was reading some stuff where they're
saying i really hope sydney is not as
scary as olivia like i don't know if i
want to meet sydney anymore i'm like oh
no no you're like the nicest person on
the planet oh things in real life but on
the show i mean it means you did a good
job to test for interacting thank you
connie britton as your mom i'm obsessed
with her how was it to have her play
your mom i mean i'm obsessed with her
too i always say like my mom and i binge
nashville together so when i first saw
her she was already in costume we were
doing a camera test in hawaii and she
was wearing like the big brimmed hat in
the sunglasses
and i was sitting there and i literally
my jaw went
and i called my mom like mom
i was fangirling along with everyone
else i feel like love is super dark and
no one ever talks about it your other
big hbo hit euphoria are you guys still
filming for season two yes we are okay
how is it going how are you feeling
about we're using i am so
beyond excited and proud of the season
so i cannot wait for everyone to see it
and all the hard work everyone's been
putting into it i know you guys had to
wait a while to get to this point where
you were filming just because of course
the the pandemic did they change
direction a lot in terms of where you
thought the show was going to go or is
it pretty much where you thought there
were definitely two different versions
of the season from before the pandemic
versus now and i really love what
this season is is that because of how
you guys have to film things or just
because they had more time to kind of
ruminate no i think it was just being
able to be allowed more time with others
very cool how would you compare this new
season to season one i know you can't
thank yourself it's definitely darker
it's more intense i don't want to say
much more without getting too much away
more shocking than white lotus
i mean it's euphoria yeah
[Music]